[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to surgeon simulator
with Wade this time
hey guys to player on the ps4
clink-clink delicate new stuff it's
technology you need to be very slow
watching beside the patient already how
did you do that I don't know like
through the cloth but Clete let's remove
that oh I'm gonna get this watch out of
here yeah maybe you're not gonna okay
let's watch this I don't need the fancy
hand job just the fancy ninja okay
that's not oh we can talk about hand
jobs all we want I'm not a broker don't
do this that's not where we were moving
we're moving the kidneys oh that's easy
is it gonna take care of the wrong way
up here thank you
Laser employees tug it out at this point
you might bite whatever connections are
left okay
sound good to me cuz that like you know
I would do most of our deliveries we
just like the ability yeah really yank
on that son of a [ __ ] apparently yeah
good job double kidney chuffa hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to surgeon simulator with
Wade here had to leave I would we said
that already but he screwed up the first
time we tried so badly that we had to do
this all over again
Bob had to go an hour and a half he's
out the door with more and we're here
with George you know that commercial
only or is that just like out the door
no people sure not sponsored by them
what are you singing it I was only
saying tire and I would say this kind of
people so we're selling slaves now so
you lost your watch again again this is
the first time we've done this you just
said we've done this I did not weed I
did not that's for you Bob your scalpels
scalpels over on the right yes you pick
those up with just a four finger in your
thumb okay very delicate very Duncan not
telling you do do now sir
put it on hey we need it put a job they
dropping it alright now what okay the
objective the game is to replace his
intestines and internal organs with as
many tools as we can okay see what I
mean you see how we're doing this is a
spoon count no that's a good question oh
so this time what you're gonna do is not
screw up okay we're just gonna cover his
face so you doesn't see the shame I'm
actually gonna try and [ __ ] oh okay Wow
why are you holding a beaker do you not
need this know our patients bleeding
yeah I know I think we just grabbed that
out of there yeah let me want to solve
this problem I solve it with that spoon
that's yeah it's just a spoon it's
totally just a spoon where did the
needle I just look it up and go right
there I don't want to lose my voice from
yelling
you're making me yell I'm gonna cut his
carotid artery he's gonna see it coming
this time
hey hey hey this game I hate it hey hate
this game I hate this game I've said
this every single time I play this game
I hate this game it is the worst game
ever made
surgery surgery surgery I'll be okay
right there right yes your drool is very
lovely on this
did you like my spit it's great I know I
didn't sit them not those hard Bobby Oh
pinto beans Bobby no no Pinto I'm not
cut one yet no oh yes hit my happiness I
told you I'm sorry we're going to get
the pop-up you're going to the fava
beans La Vina well done thank you I know
I'm look at this I'm very talented get
this bag of bile out of you well do you
know how to get best food okay it's food
what are you doing I've got the spoon
we're doing good
get out come spoon mystery person off Oh
jump the spoon no we actually needed the
Hat again with it I got it oh my god I
got it oh my god holy Joe we could use
to scoop it out got it Oh
oh my god oh god [ __ ] oh no oh it's Jay
let me just grab everything else out
first
oh okay I'm gonna hold it three
carefully all right
oh [ __ ] well okay wait wait wait wait
[Music]
all right oh that needles okay you got
it I got it
okay so the spoon give his proper
leverage to scoop it out of there you
should just drop the spoon Oh No so
stupid this game is so stupid this game
so stupid hate it hate oh that might be
in grabbing because right around that
[Music]
yes yes havoc alright oh you haven't
pulled out I got it yes
Oh yep dinner later oh wait oh god no oh
why is this open oh don't look that does
it no you do not
oh my god did I lose that Oh son of a
[ __ ] I swear I'm going for the other
one okay got it
no don't got it why can't I grab it well
I can't I swear to god you're not
clapping act okay stop stop stop I can't
move oh my god no stop yelling why
couldn't you do that before I couldn't
you grabbed it I was doing fine until
you put it in point line right up there
it was all that crazy crazy idea I'm
just holding on as I did to get over
here okay so I can grab someone I just
need something to try to
[Music]
okay
all right
[Music]
is a crazy idea of [ __ ] goddamn that
was in perfect position to everything it
was a crazy idea crazy it could never
work wait wait wait wait we go down I'm
just gonna sit right there no come on
okay oh my god no oh no oh no
okay just scoop it yes a little closer
oh my saw went away where's the hammer
uh-huh what Sam we're dealing here
hammer we don't know anything we don't
know God we lost a hammer
it took ah then you can use his
intestines to scoop it up yeah okay it's
down right there
okay Oh
I don't know what's going on right there
oh no no I had it I had the chance of it
[ __ ] it up can't grab anything
belonging to my saws [ __ ] gone
[ __ ] hate this game so much there I
know it's there
[Music]
I hate my life I hate every dot [ __ ]
thing about let's get good [ __ ] hate
it
[ __ ] [ __ ] no done [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
alright [ __ ] that [ __ ] everything about
this it's a piece of [ __ ] game don't buy
it it's awful [ __ ] boss the studio's
I've met the developers [ __ ] meets
every single goddamn lawn bum in the
face [ __ ] you
not you viewers [ __ ] you
here good pleasure thank you
[Music]
thank you all for watching this videos
always welcome to decided to show its
face down we got our new part there we
go so you only have a certain ability to
spend down you can't make it look like a
penis